the wrangling between the court and the
defense team threatened to further delay
the trial the day began with the
defendants entering a motion demanding a
bigger courtroom to allow more people to
follow the trial after the court
rejected the demands the charges against
Beata chepa were finally read out she's
accused of having helped plan and
organize the murders and other attacks
allegedly carried out by ube bernhardt
and even wind blows the victims
relatives and their lawyers are relieved
the trial is finally moving forward
it's been I'm very happy the trial is
proceeding that the decisions have been
made and the indictment read out like
fleas I think in the past few weeks
we've lost enough time with formalities
and we should now proceed with the real
work when we get into the ho about
Jordan the indictment also charges
Chiapas four co-defendants of being
accessories to the crimes they're
accused of supplying the NSU trio with a
weapon and false identity cards and
organizing accommodation for them with
the initial procedural maneuvering now
complete the lawyers can begin
addressing the evidence